[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLLEEN SHOGAN: Good morning.
My name is Colleen Shogan.
I work at the
Library of Congress.
I'm the assistant deputy
librarian for Collections
and Services, and I'm pleased
to be here this morning
to talk to you about
some exciting new work
that we're working on here
at the Library of Congress
in Washington, DC.
And in particular, I'm here to
talk to you about the National
Library Service for the Blind
and Physically Handicapped,
which is a program and division
within the Library of Congress.
And what I'll refer to--
this is a very long
name for a program,
but I'll refer to it going
forward as simply NLS.
And that's what we
refer to it as well.
I'm here to give
you an overview.
By the way, I'm a
political scientist.
I'm not a technologist
or an engineer.
But I'm here to give
you an overview of NLS
and this unique program
within the federal government.
As this slide says, NLS has
been in existence since 1931.
And the vision of NLS,
the vision statement
is "so that all may read."
What NLS is is a free
program for those
who are visually impaired or
print-disabled to provide what
you would call audio books,
what we call talking books,
to United States citizens
all across the country.
And NLS, to talk to you
a little bit about it,
there's about 100 people.
A little bit over 100
people who work at NLS.
Like I said, it is a
program or division
within the Library of Congress.
It's located in the Petworth
neighborhood of Washington, DC.
So a little bit apart from where
the main Library of Congress
campus is situated
on Capitol Hill.
It has its own appropriation.
It has its own funding
within the federal government
part of the Library of Congress,
but a separate appropriation
that's dedicated
specifically for books
for the blind and
print-disabled.
And currently right now, NLS
receives about $53 million
a year in which to do this.
Right now, NLS-- and this is
what I'm going to talk a little
bit about--
the distribution of those
audio books or talking books
is done both through an analog--
so physical delivery through the
United States Postal Service--
and also through
digital delivery.
And that's how the
program works right now.
Here's a few
statistics about NLS.
I'll talk a little bit,
give you a little bit
about the overview.
And then I want to talk to
you about how NLS works.
This is a little misleading.
It says that there's
970-some thousand accounts.
That really translates
into about 450,000 users
across the United States.
And in addition to
these users, there
are about 100 network
libraries that partner
with the Library of
Congress in which
to distribute these books.
And this is how it works.
So if you sign up for the
NLS and you are eligible,
once you are determined that you
are eligible for the program,
you receive an account.
You also receive what we
call a digital talking books
machine in which you
can play analog delivery
of these talking books, which is
essentially a thumb drive that
is sent to your home.
You could also bring
your own device
and download the books digitally
through our online website,
which is called BARD.
So those are the two ways that
you're able to get your books.
Right now, either way,
whether you receive your books
digitally or whether
you receive them
in the mail to play them on your
digital talking books machine,
most of our users rely upon the
librarians at those 100 network
libraries for
assistance in deciding
what books they
want to listen to
and curating the
list of books that
are in their queue to be read.
Now I'd like to talk a little
bit about where we're headed.
So that's where
we are right now.
It's a very successful program.
It's a very popular
program with, obviously,
our users, the visually
impaired community,
and also with Congress.
But this is where we're headed.
We are embarking into
a very exciting time
I think in NLS' history, the
Library of Congress' history.
We're undertaking a
modernization effort
for the next five
to seven years.
And the goal of this
modernization effort
is to move NLS from a
predominantly analog service--
right now about 90% of our
users receive their books
in the mail from the
US Postal Service--
to a predominantly
digital service.
So that's where
we are right now,
and that's where
we want to head.
There are some
challenges with that.
Because of course,
any changes we
want to make in the delivery
of our talking books
has to take into
account our users.
And as you might imagine with
a visually impaired community
of users, most of our users skew
towards the older age spectrum.
So we're very sensitive
about creating and taking
advantage of technologies
that will be acceptable
and can be used by our
patrons and the people who
rely upon us for books.
We do have a aggressive strategy
in the next five to seven
years.
As I said before, we have
currently about 450,000 users
across the United States.
We would like to increase
that to 1 million users
across the United States in
the next five to seven years
as the result of modernization.
And really what
we're talking about
is elevating
digital experiences.
And what that means
to myself and how
I think about that is that
my vision is for NLS users
to be able to
consume talking books
and read books the same
way that you or I are
used to consuming books.
And that means being able
to download and have access
to books on demand.
If you hear about a
book on TV or the radio
or you hear about
it from a friend,
you're able to
download that book.
If you read digitally,
you're able to download
that book immediately
and then begin reading it
if you so choose.
If you don't like that book
or it's not what you expected,
you're able to switch streams
and download a different book
immediately and start that book.
And having the ability to be
able to do that for myself
as a reader has really changed
the way I consume books.
And it makes for a much
more enriching experience.
And that's the vision that we
want to bring to our NLS users
right now.
Not that they necessarily have
to wait three to five days
for that cartridge
to come in the mail,
but that they're able to have
access to those audio books
right now online.
And where we're headed
is relying primarily
on a bring-your-own-device
model in the future,
with perhaps a digital talking
book machine that's provided
to those users who need it.
And we definitely want to
move to a technology that's
platform-agnostic so that
we can have people that
bring the devices that
they're comfortable with be
able to use them and take
advantage of NLS services.
And what we're doing
right now is NLS
is in the very early stages--
we're really in year 0 of
this modernization effort,
with it kicking off next year.
And what we're doing right now
is doing small pilot projects
to figure out which technologies
can best serve our user
and patron base in the future.
And that brings
us to the subject
of today's presentation, which
is focused on the voice user
interface, which is one
of the pilot projects
that NLS is engaged
in this year.
So trying to figure out
how can we use voice user
interface in the
future for our patrons
who want to search for a book.
For example, I want
to read biographies.
I want to read romances.
I want to read westerns.
How can they have that
interactive experience working
with artificial intelligence,
with a voice user interface,
that will enable them to get
the right books in their queue
and that they will
be able to enjoy?
They also need to be able
to listen to those books--
most of our patrons will listen
to a book from start to finish.
For example, how you might
read a fiction book, or even
most nonfiction books.
But other users will want
particular books in which they
need to skip around,
so you have to be
able to use the voice
automated interface to be
able to move to different
points in the book.
For example, if you are
reading a recipe or a cookbook,
or if you're reading
a travel book,
are good examples
where you wouldn't
read that book
necessarily sequentially,
but focusing on particular
parts of the book
that you find
interesting or relevant.
So right now where
the library is--
and we're going to see a demo
here from some of my colleagues
that I think is very promising.
Right now where the
Library of Congress is,
we've issued an RFI--
Request For Information-- about
search, discovery, and playback
for audiobooks for
the visually impaired
using smart speaker technology
on a vendor-agnostic platform.
And that's just our process
of gathering more information
in this very early
pre-stage of modernization
so that we're able to make
the best strategic decisions
in the future for the
modernization of our services
to the blind, visually
impaired, and print-disabled.
It's also important for us, I
will say the last thing that's
important for us, is security.
Because the National
Library Service of the Blind
and Physically Handicapped has
an exception to legislation
to copyright
provisions that enable
them to share books to the
users of the NLS community.
But we want to make
sure that whenever
we put these books
out there that only
our NLS users are being
authorized to listen and take
advantage of them.
So security is also of
utmost importance for us,
and also to our patrons.
So now I'm going to turn it
over to my colleagues who
are going to talk a little
bit about their work,
their technical work in this
area that they've done already.
And they will also
show us a demo
which is really a product
of all their hard work.
PRABHU PALANISAMY:
Thanks, Colleen.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Prabhu Palanisamy.
I'm from the SpringML team.
We had the privilege of working
with the Library of Congress
in building the pilot and
demo associated with it.
Show of hands-- I'll pretend
that I will be able to see--
how many of you in the
room has a smartphone?
How many of you have a Google
Home or a device in your house?
How many of you have
more than one device?
That's the age we
live in, right?
Obviously, parents
in the room know
how their kids are able to
make use of the Google Homes
effectively than us.
Voice interface is
becoming their primary
more of communication for
many of the applications that
are being built today.
Here is an image of
the talking devices
that are being developed.
And the technology
enablement happened in waves,
innovation-wise, at the
Library of Congress.
This was displayed in the Hall
of the Library of Congress
when we were doing the project.
So cassette record players.
And the one in the
middle is the device that
is used by the patrons today.
They have to go to the library.
They have to get the
right device in place
and then use it to read books.
Like, when we were
surveying, on the project,
there were patrons
who read, like,
three to four books a week.
And they read at a
pace of around 1.75
to 2x compared to a normal
reader who is reading visually.
They play it fast.
They are able to grasp
the content much faster
than the rest of the people.
[? Two ?] levels
[? sets, ?] right?
From a technology project,
this is very, very easy
for us to map it.
That's the device.
That's the technology that
they are exposed today.
And the solution is right
in front of you guys.
Having a device that they
can interact over voice
and get the content that
they are looking for.
To look at it, for a general
audience, we have e-books.
That's the primary choice
that we use these days.
Apps, Google
Assistant, mobile apps,
smart phones that
we interact with.
And again, the third one is
the conversational interface.
That's the exposure
of technology
for common people like us.
And how about having this
technology to the other folks
that we want to enable them?
Like Colleen mentioned,
they have a vision
of making sure that
the 400,000 folks are
getting enabled and getting
the value out of it.
In simple terms,
this is the vision
we wanted to implement
on a project.
Sitting in a home on
evening when they come back,
when they say play a
book, and the system
starts to be able to
understand the user profile.
Goes through the security, the
authentication, the look up,
and then the book
starts to play.
Simple terms.
But imagine for a
moment how powerful
the life changes for folks
who can get this value.
And then from the
Library of Congress team,
how about we do it
for all the books?
The journals?
Publications?
Way [? there ?] [? are a ?]
[? search ?] [? that ?]
[? the ?] [? team ?] [? has ?]
[? it, ?] and we can enable it
for the folks for
a general audience.
Now, I think we
have set the stage.
This is the device
that the patrons use.
And this is the end goal.
You know, using a conversational
interface and play the books.
How did we do it, and what are
some of the success criterias
to consider for a
project like this?
Number one, it's
a conversational.
It's not like a resource--
you click on a button
or open a page, and then go
through a normal application.
It should be a
human conversation.
Hey, I'm interested in
a science fiction book,
or I'm interested
in a cooking recipe.
Can you list out the books
that are of interest to me?
I'm interested in a book by
a specific author or a genre
that I need to look up.
It needs to be a
highly conversational
in terms of interaction-wise.
The other thing is interactive,
where it's not about a book
and the system plays it.
How do we make it
more interactive?
Like go to the next
chapter, pause,
come back to the
synopsis of the book,
or read me the title
and the contents.
We want to make it
highly interactive,
so that way it's not
about finding the resource
and playing the
resource, but how
would a human converse and
interact with an application?
The last and very
important one is scale.
This is not a project for
a certain subset of people
or certain subset of books.
We want to solve it at scale.
When we want to
load 100 books, it
should be the same process
to load 1,000, 10,000,
and a million books.
Imagine for a moment
we solve the problems,
and then in order to scale it,
probably enterprise consultants
or IT in the room
would have gone
through the struggle of
building a project is one thing.
Building an application.
What's the scale in
that application?
We want to do it in one
platform that supports
this end-to-end pipeline.
So without further
any delay, I would
like to invite Amit Deshpande
from our SpringML team
to go through the demo of it.
AMIT DESHPANDE: Hello, everyone.
Thank you, Prabhu.
So we'll get into the demo.
So I'm not sure how
many of you have
worked on Dialogflow, but--
all right.
How many of you have actually
worked on Dialogflow?
Developers out there.
All right.
Great.
Thanks.
So what we've done is
we've built a Dialogflow
system out here-- application.
And it's right now in the beta
stage, like Colleen mentioned.
It's a pilot.
And we have tried
to make sure that we
take care of all the nuances
that the library wanted--
make sure that
it's scalable, it's
usable across
multiple platforms,
and highly conversational,
and all the good stuff.
All right, let's get
started with the demo.
So what I'm going to do
is, unlike your usual way
of talking to Google and
saying, hey, Google, I'm
going to trigger
it from my mobile.
So let's do it.
[ACTIVATION SOUND]
NLS BOT: Sure.
Getting NLS bot.
[BEEPING]
Sure.
Welcome to the library.
Here you can search
for books, play books,
or add them to your
collection for later reading.
How can I help?
AMIT DESHPANDE: Can
you read a book for me?
NLS BOT: Please specify
the title of the book.
Check our title list
if you are unsure.
AMIT DESHPANDE: OK.
Do you have books
by Winterbottom?
NLS BOT: Is it one,
Booth Tarkington.
Two, Deborah Biancotti.
Three, Michael Koryta?
Please choose the number.
AMIT DESHPANDE: None of them.
NLS BOT: OK then.
We have many books
from science fiction
to spy fiction to
the autobiographies.
Say a book title, genre,
or author to learn more.
AMIT DESHPANDE: What books
on science do you have?
NLS BOT: Is it one, Rina Singh.
Two, [INAUDIBLE].
Three, Amy Siskind?
Please choose the number.
AMIT DESHPANDE: Well,
what about travel books?
NLS BOT: Our
available travel books
include one, "The
Monk of Mokha."
Two, "Time Pieces."
Three, "Himalaya Bound."
Which book would
you like me to play?
Choose the book number.
AMIT DESHPANDE:
Any more options?
NLS BOT: Here are the
additional travel books.
Four, "Eating Eternity-- Food,
Art, and Literature in France."
Five, "A Tokyo Romance--
a Memoir."
Six, "The Long Haul--
A Trucker's Tales of
Life on the Road."
Which one would
you like to hear?
Please say the book number.
AMIT DESHPANDE: What
about books on food?
NLS BOT: Our available
cooking books
include one, "Joy of Cooking."
Two, "The Reporter's Kitchen."
Three, "What She Ate."
Which book would
you like me to play?
Choose the book number.
AMIT DESHPANDE: OK.
Play "Pride and Prejudice."
NLS BOT: Is it "Pride
and Prejudice?"
AMIT DESHPANDE: Yes.
NLS BOT: OK.
Now reading "Pride
and Prejudice."
CHRIS GORINGE: This is
a LibriVox recording.
All LibriVox recordings
are in the public domain.
For more information,
please visit librivox.org.
Today's reading,
"Pride and Prejudice"
by Jane Austen,
chapters 1 to 3, read
by Chris Goringe, chapter 1.
AMIT DESHPANDE: Hey, Google.
Pause.
All right.
So I was able to do
a few of the things
that Prabhu mentioned
already, right?
So I was able to log
in to Google Home
into the application.
I was able to search
by author names.
I was able to search by
genres, multiple genres.
So I said let's get
some travel books.
Let's get books on food.
So if you heard
the response there
when I asked for
books on food, it
said here are books
on eating or cooking.
So it was able to intelligently
get the right type of books.
And then finally, we are able
to play the book as well.
I am able to pause
it, but we are also
having the capabilities
to do a fast forward,
to rewind, start over,
all the good things.
So the other features which
also are in the pipeline,
going to be added--
like Prabhu mentioned,
we should be able to read
it at a faster pace instead
of this pace.
So that's in the
pipeline as well.
OK.
So let me start
with what challenges
we faced with this project.
So when we started
the project, we
were told about the
scale of the project--
how many users were there,
what sort of information we had
about how many books were
there, and the size of the book.
For example, if you want to
play some of these audio files,
they're really large.
I mean, they could be
running in GBs, right?
They are really large books.
We had to get the
information instantly.
There are millions of books
that should be stored.
It should have various
categories of information,
like the title.
You've got various different
synonyms possibily.
You've got author names.
And then, like
Colleen mentioned,
security is a big deal.
We had to make sure that the
audio files that we are using,
they have to be secure.
And they are not
accessible by anybody
else other than the
patrons who are already
registered with the system.
And obviously, we have
to target massive scales
so that if the users
go beyond millions,
we have to take care of that.
And as the number
of books gets added,
we have the system
in place which
allows the administrators
to seamlessly add
those books into the system.
Make it available.
So all interesting challenges.
And more importantly,
with Dialogflow,
make it extremely
conversational and intelligent.
That's the key here.
So that if someone even says the
wrong things, if the books are
not there, make sure
you propose new ways
of searches or different
intelligent responses.
That's the key part.
So I'll go with the high
level architecture over here.
So if you see, there
are five boxes.
The first two are
the channels which
are available for
accessing the system.
You've got support
from Google Assistant
on mobile and Google Home.
You can use these two
channels, or Google Mini
as well, to connect to
this particular system--
the library.
The conversation
management obviously
is being handled by
the Dialogflow engine.
And finally, you
got the fulfillment,
and that's going to be handled
by the Cloud Functions.
That's what we've
used using Node.js.
The Cloud Functions in turn
connect to the Firestore.
That's where all the
metadata about these books
is being stored.
So what's the title?
What's the author?
What are the chapters there?
And then finally the
storage of the audio
files itself is going
into Google Cloud Storage.
So most of the scale
issues-- obviously, this is
what Google is great at, right?
I mean, it provides scale.
So using the Google
Cloud Storage,
we were able to upload
terabytes of data.
No issues at all.
And we were able to collect
metadata about the books,
upload it into the Firestore.
No issues at all.
And it's not mentioned
here, but we also
had to make sure that the
metadata that's getting
added into Firestore-- we have
the right jobs which collect
that information and create
entities out of that,
and get it in sync
into the Dialogflow.
So that's the high
level architecture.
So let's go into the flow now.
What exactly is happening?
What are the systems
being used out here?
So a user speaks
into Google Home,
and the first task that
happens there is it
makes sure that the user who
has logged into the Google Home.
You have to set up Google Home.
And at that point, you obviously
need to sign up, right?
And that's the
information that we
are going to use through
the whole system.
There's SSOs-- Single Sign
On-- all over the place.
And the start point is
really the authentication
into the Google Home.
So what happens next?
So a user speaks
into Google Home.
And then that request
goes into the Actions
on Google, which is the
platform that Google provides
for executing your software
or actions on the Google
Home or the Google Assistant.
At this point, the
voice recording
that was done through Google
Home, is converted into text.
And then it goes
into the Dialogflow.
When the sentence, the converted
sentence reaches Dialogflow,
it's essentially going
to take that sentence,
convert it into the intents, and
extract the entities required.
Once you have the
intent in place,
we are connecting this
system to the Cloud Function.
So this information is
part of the Cloud Function.
And that's where we have
intent handlers in place,
which are going to
read this information
and do the relevant tasks.
So what is it that a particular
intent is required to do?
So let's go to the next slide.
So suppose we had
to do book search.
And when you have
to do book search,
someone is going
to say, all right,
I want to get a book
based on a certain genre.
So the Cloud Function
is going to receive
that particular intent,
which is to search for a book
by a genre.
And it is going to the
Firestore and making
sure we have those
kind of books.
And if it does, then it returns
that particular response,
sends it back to the
Dialogflow in text,
which is then sent back
to the Actions on Google.
And Actions on Google is going
to convert that text into voice
and release it back
to Google Home.
So that's the flow for
the typical searches.
And when you want
to screen the audio,
the same thing happens all over.
The request is going to the
Google Home, then converted
to the Actions on Google.
The voice is
converted to the text.
Goes to Dialogflow.
Cloud Function.
And in the Cloud
Function, we now
know that the intent
is to play an audio.
And when you want
to play an audio,
then you first want to check
if that particular audio file
exists or not.
So we go to the Firestore,
get the information
of whether the
audio exists or not.
And once we find that
the audio exists,
we have systems in place
where we have a mapping
essentially that the file
which exists in the Firestore,
we know that there is a
certain file in Cloud Storage.
We go and essentially hit
the Cloud Storage and check
for that file.
That file is being read back and
sent to the Actions on Google.
And that is what is
starting to pretty much play
the whole audio file.
And once it starts, it
takes over from there.
And it's playing-- it's
allowing you to pause,
fast forward,
repeat, start over,
and all the good functionalities
that Actions on Google
provides.
So for those who want to
know of the technical detail
here, like I said, there are
huge files involved over here--
GBs.
So one of the big challenge
that we had was, all right.
How do we read this out?
If you're going to read up GBs
of data and put it into memory,
you know what's going to happen.
It's going to crash
the system, right?
So we had to make
sure it's streaming.
So we use the media object that
Actions on Google provides.
And luckily, that handles
streaming brilliantly.
We were able to just go
forward to, like, an hour
into the book, and it
just continues playing.
No issues at all.
Amazing stuff there, right?
We were able to go back.
Ask it to go back in time.
Start over.
No problems at all.
So the streaming was a big deal.
And luckily, the media
object that Actions on Google
provides handles
that beautifully.
And like I said, the security
is another interesting aspect.
And I have not really
mentioned that explicitly
in the slide over there.
But when you hit
the Cloud Function,
there's a second level of
security happening over there.
So first level is where
the Google Home itself
is saying that, hey, I've
authenticated myself.
It goes to Actions on Google.
It's authenticated there.
And then the SSO passes on.
And then Dialogflow says hey,
we're all good with this user.
But when it hits the
Cloud Function, what we do
is essentially take
those credentials back--
especially the email ID.
And then in the back
end, we have the patrons
basically registered.
So there is a
separate system going
to be in place which is
registering these users.
And the Cloud Function is--
obviously, that's
stored in the Firestore.
And we are making sure that
those users are authenticated
a second time.
And only those users
can access the files.
And again, the important
thing is since it's copyright,
it's stored in
the cloud storage.
But we need to make
sure that it's not
possible to download the files.
So it's all being streamed.
So there's no chance of
these files being downloaded.
So those are the details
that I wanted to present--
the demo, the
architecture, and the flow.
With that, I'll
hand over to Dan,
who is going to cover what's
the art of the possible
with Dialogflow.
DAN ORBACH: Thanks, Amit.
Good morning, everybody.
So far what we've
heard-- we've heard
from Colleen about the
National Library Service
and its mission
to enable reading
for the blind and
physically handicapped.
We've heard from Prabhu and Amit
about the pilot that we ran,
the various architectures
for that pilot,
the challenges for that pilot.
What I'm going to talk
about is going to be the--
what I'm going to
talk about will
be kind of taking this into
the art of the possible.
What can we do that we
haven't done in the pilot
to extend it and
add features that
will be useful for the patrons?
I will go through some key
features in Dialogflow,
as well as other use cases that
are being used with Dialogflow.
And we'll also go through
the speech-to-text
and the text-to-Speech
APIs briefly, again
with highlight of key features
and highlight of case studies
that are being used today.
So we saw a cool demo.
We saw Amit try
different things.
Actually change up.
You heard all the ums
and ahs, and thinking
about how to ask the question--
all the things that are
inherent in human speech.
And when you think
about it, when
we're saying we want the
interface to be conversational,
what we're saying is--
I can speak in the affirmative.
I can answer a
question with yes,
or I can answer it with
absolutely, or sure,
or definitely, or let's
go ahead with that.
And a formal interactive
voice response system,
it's going to be very, very
difficult for that system
to understand what it is
that I'm trying to say.
And therefore you
need some system
that understands the nuance
and syntax of the language
to be able to translate that
into something very specific
and get around that my
intent was to move forward.
My answer was an affirmative.
So when we now look, how
effective was that demo,
and can the patrons use that
effectively, the first thing
we want to look at
is actually something
that's called Analytics.
It's actually available
already today in Dialogflow.
And when we scale the
system to many, many users,
short of just
serving the users--
which we certainly want to do
to understand their experience
of the system--
wouldn't it be nice
if we could get a flow
tree of what are the intents?
And by the way,
when we say intents,
we're talking about actions.
What is it that
I'm trying to do?
I'm trying to play a book.
I'm trying to search a book.
Where do the users
actually focus?
So you're seeing
here a depiction--
this is direct from
Dialogflow Enterprise.
And the thicker lines
show you the percentage
or the more popular flow of that
conversation of the intents.
And so we know where the
users are navigating today.
And that gives us a level of
insight into what is being used
or potentially what should
be changed or enhanced
in the system.
How many times do we fall
back into a no-match action,
and what do we need
to do about that?
How many actions--
how deep do we
need to go from specifying
an intent to actually getting
a fulfillment or action behind
it, like a playback of a book
or the list of books
that we're looking for?
So how deep is this?
And all of that is really
important in understanding
the effectiveness of your model.
Now you also noticed, or you may
have noticed, that there are--
so Dialogflow can support
multiple languages.
This particular interaction
that you heard on demo
was actually set on its
preferences on Google Home,
or specifically, the Assistant.
So that locale and
the dialect can
change to suit the
patrons' user preferences.
Now there's a thing called
the conversation style.
And it would be
naive of me to think
that that interaction
that you heard
is actually going
to serve everybody--
a full set of diverse
set of patrons.
And the reason is
that we all have
slightly different preferences.
I mean, you saw in the demo
it said, you know, say one
for this book.
Say two for this book.
Say three for that book.
I may or may not
like that interface.
I may prefer to
just say the name.
I may prefer, maybe
when I learn it,
I may prefer to just say
one, or the first one,
or the third one, and not
have it read out to me
that instruction.
So the notion of a
conversation style
is something that
can be introduced.
The art of the possible.
So to give you a quick example
on the one end of this,
I might have a very
verbose conversation.
The Assistant, the Dialogflow
app comes and says,
what do you want to read?
I have books of this kind.
I have books of that kind.
These are the types
of instructions
you can give me so I can
help you find your book.
When you make a selection, just
like we heard with Amit when
he selected "Pride
and Prejudice,"
the system came back
and said, you've
selected "Pride and Prejudice."
Is that correct?
And he could say
yes, it is correct.
So when I'm a first
time user of the system,
I want to get that comfort
that the system understands me.
And it knows what it is
that I'm trying to do.
On the flip side, I might
be an experienced user.
I want to cut to the chase.
Don't give me all this info.
Let's just play this book.
Think of the shortcuts.
Think of single utterances.
So how can I design
a system that,
based on my user preferences,
will give me the interface that
best suits me?
And that's what we
were talking about
with conversational styles.
Now, book collections--
think of it
much like a wish list or
a recommendation engine.
So as a user, we're already
said as a patron, I will log in.
I will authenticate.
That kind of proves who I am.
We know that I've been
eligible for the program.
We know that's important for
digital rights management
perspective purposes.
And when I create a
book collection, when
I say recommendation engine,
the first thing a tech
audience will say is, yeah,
we know what that means.
Absolutely.
But in reality, here what
you have is the patrons
have a very personal
relationship, in many cases,
with their local librarians.
As Colleen mentioned, they
rely on their guidance
and knowledge.
And they appreciate that.
But what we can do
here potentially
is have these local librarians
insert books into your wish
list so that you still maintain
that personal interaction,
but move forward
with-- you can still
augment your system-generated
recommendations
or personally inserted notes.
The other thing is to be
able to add annotations
and notes to the book.
So for this, perhaps I'm
doing some kind of study.
Think a study guide where
I can add my own notes
and information.
And I want to maintain
that alongside that place
in the book so that
I can come back
to this later on, and perhaps
even search out later on.
Content searching.
So in the pilot today,
primarily you had three things.
You had the book title, you had
author, and you had the genre.
But what if I want to search
for chocolate cake recipes
across a corpus of
books or content?
So now being able to
search within the book
and have it come back and
provide me some options.
That's certainly
art of the possible.
Dynamically assembling
content would
be something similar
to what I just
mentioned, where I'm taking
content from multiple places
every time that
Mr. So-and-so has
spoken on a particular topic.
And I want to get all
of those clipped out,
basically, and created
into a dynamic book.
Think of it that way.
Notifications, reminders.
Again, that could be
new content available.
That could be my book club
book is about to start reading.
My class is about to start.
Just having Google
Home notify me.
And then finally, real quick
on the art of the possible
is just what
happens to me a lot.
I start reading a book,
and then I get distracted.
And two, three days
later, I'm back.
Or maybe two or
three weeks later,
I'm back or maybe even
a month later, I'm back.
And now I've forgotten
everything that I've read.
Because my memory
needs an upgrade,
and I just don't
remember things anymore.
So wouldn't it be nice,
similar to TV shows
where you see in the
last episode of this,
this is what happened.
Wouldn't it be nice
if we could actually
go back a couple of paragraphs,
summarize that content--
programmatically--
and come back with,
this is what you read
last, just to remind you
the context of where you were?
And a little bit
further into the future
is voice-enabled research.
I'll move forward in
the interest of time.
So we spoke about
analytics as well already.
But sentiment
analysis-- so think
about, as the interaction
grows and moves forward,
what kind of information can
I get about the language that
is used by the patron,
and are they getting
frustrated with the interface?
Again, a way for us
to very quickly assess
the effectiveness
of an interface.
There are training phrases
that you use with Dialogflow
to train it.
And that's how you can tell it
how to use different language.
And very briefly, the
training phrase will actually
be taken by Dialogflow
and it'll match it
to an intent or an action
you're trying to achieve,
and will match
entities or things
that you're talking about
within your conversation.
It's a way for you
to train something
that is not so formal in terms
of the conversational aspect.
I'll move forward past
some of the items here.
Maybe touch on
multi-platform real quick.
There are a variety
of integrations.
So for example, I
could just as well
have used Alexa, Cortana, Slack,
Skype, Twitter, as integrations
into Dialogflow.
And the benefit there is
having the same engine
behind the scenes, but
different interfaces
from the patrons' perspective.
And real quick, on
two of the use cases--
you're seeing a bunch
of use cases here.
I'll touch on two real quick.
One of them is Starkey,
Starkey Hearing Technologies.
It's a company that
makes hearing aids.
And they have I guess a brand
of Livio and Livio AI hearing
aids.
And they're actually the world's
first "healthable" hearing aid
with embedded sensors and AI.
And what they do is they make
it easy for their customers who
use their hearing aids to
understand what features,
what settings they can
use on their hearing aids.
And they actually
use Dialogflow to be
able to enable that setting
so they can talk to their app.
They have an app called Thrive.
And they can talk to this
app and actually enhance
the settings that makes sense
for them through Dialogflow.
A second example is a company
called Polydice out of Taiwan.
And what they did was they
built a social network
to enable users to be able
to find and share recipes--
literally.
So find and share recipes.
And they're using Dialogflow.
Why is that interesting?
Well number one is
you can talk to it.
And you tell it this is
what I'm looking for.
These are my preferences.
But secondarily,
I'm taking those,
capturing those preferences, and
I can create a recommendation
engine behind it
for what recipes
I might want to give you, or
which users I might suggest
you share your recipe with.
So that's real interesting.
So Speech API.
Speech API is actually broken
into two pieces speech-to-text
and text-to-speech.
Most of these examples that
I'm going to talk about
are speech-to-text, but I
will touch on text-to-speech
as well.
The ability to handle a single
or multi-channels, which
basically means that if I have
multiple speakers, each one
on a different channel, that
I'd be able to take that all
and incorporate it into a single
transcription of what's said.
The ability to
detect the language.
So I can actually provided
with a list of four languages
that I'm expecting and
have it detect the language
and transcribe on the fly.
The ability to use voice models.
This is very interesting.
So you have the
ability-- you know,
is the source of the
audio a phone call?
Is the source of
the audio a command?
the audio a video?
And when you think about
it-- so if it's a command,
it's typically almost a
single utterance or something.
It will be a
2-to-10-second invocation.
If it's a phone call,
it might be, say,
a 4 minute conversation.
And if it's a video, it
could be 2 hours-plus.
And you might say, damn.
Four minutes on the phone.
There's no way.
And I might be
aging myself here,
because I remember phone calls
going into hours and hours,
way eclipsing the video.
Having said that, the
youngsters of today
are loath to speak on the
phone in the first place,
so I would say it
averages out nicely.
But seriously, the artifact
that we're looking for--
each of those environments
brings a different collection
of artifacts with it.
For example, the command
is a single person.
And they're usually
short utterances.
The phone call
will be two people
with a static on the line.
There might be other things.
Perhaps two to three people,
depending on the conference.
And the video will bring, again,
different background noise
and a different context.
So each one of them can be
handled by different models
to make it more accurate.
Real quick-- phrase hints.
Phrase hints is a way for us
to train the dictionary so
to speak, of the transcription.
So at Next, we announced
something called Anthos.
Actually, "antho,"
I believe, comes
from the Greek word of flower.
Anthos is a new word.
Maybe my model doesn't
know what it is.
Well, I can add a phrase here
to say when you hear this,
don't break it out
into "an--" gibberish.
I want you to
actually say Anthos.
So I'm going to give it
as a phrase hint for it
to recognize
something that I want.
And it could be a word.
It could be a sentence.
I'll just touch on two more
here real quick, because I'm
running out of time.
One of them is
speaker diarization.
So we talked about
multiple channels.
We might have four
people in a conversation.
How do we transcribe that?
And what we're doing
with speaker diarization
is we're actually providing
a speaker number or a talker
number along with
the transcription.
So you're seeing the graphic.
You've got one speaker in
red, one speaker in yellow.
What I'm able to do is say,
speaker 1 said the following.
Speaker 2 followed up
with this response.
Speaker 1 continued.
And it can actually do
that for as many speakers
as it can recognize
within a channel.
So as long as it's not too many
and too close, it can do that.
All right.
Two quick examples here.
One of them is on
the speech-to-text.
VTCSecure is a
technology organization
that makes services
for the hearing
impaired or the deaf community.
And specifically,
they had an initiative
where they were helping
them find jobs and go
through job fairs.
And they used the
speech-to-text capability
to help the hearing
impaired actually converse
with their interviewer.
A second example would be
on the text-to-speech side
of the house.
You may be familiar
with Ingram Content.
And they are a distributor
of many, many books
and publications.
And what they do
is they're actually
able to use text-to-speech to
provide audio book previews
and readouts of all the
various books that they have.
So just again, interesting use
cases for the speech-to-text
API.
And with that, I
will call on Prabhu
to take us through
the takeaways.
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Perfect.
Thanks, Dan.
So if you have any questions,
we are happy to answer.
[? We ?] [? don't ?]
[? know if ?] Google Home is
here.
So no issues.
To wrap up, first, from a
project, this is a one way--
technology was one aspect of it.
But really, understanding
the human interactions,
like how users will request for
a book, request for it to play,
request for it to search--
having that interaction
clearly laid out.
Then descend for scale.
Like implementing
a project, like
to load 100 books
versus a million.
We want to have the solution,
to have the scale and the reach.
Then, very important, security.
These particular
resources are copyrighted.
Not for everyone to log
in and then go through it.
And then integrations.
Today, we want to do for a
certain platform like, say,
Google Home, but we want
to make it agnostic.
Like if users have
their forms that they
have Google Assistant with or
any other modes of interaction,
we want to have a platform that
supports multiple integrations
into it.
So key takeaways-wise to quickly
wrap up-- human interactions,
conversational style, design for
scale, security built into it,
and support for
multiple integrations.
Thanks, everyone.
[MUSIC PLAYING]